♪♪
Let's get to the news.
Following the news
that Kentucky Derby winner
Medina Spirit had failed
a post-race drug test,
former President Trump
released a statement
on his website yesterday,
that said,
"So now even our
Kentucky Derby winner,
Medina Spirit, is a junky,"
which brings us to a segment
called
"Dammit, That's Really Funny."
[ Theme music plays ]
Okay, obviously,
I dislike this man.
But it is possible
to dislike someone
and think calling a horse
a junkie is very, very funny.
This was an official statement
from the former president,
calling a horse a junkie.
As if it bought the drugs itself
in some back alley.
Like it only got caught
'cause the horse's parents
found it in a shoebox
under its bed, its stable?
Again, I cannot stress enough,
I do not like this man.
But, dammit, it's really funny.
-This has been...
-Maryland Governor Larry Hogan
criticized
his fellow Republicans
in an interview yesterday
for continuing to support
former President Trump,
and said, "It just bothers me
that you have to swear fealty
to the dear leader, or you get
kicked out of the party."
If only there was a way
that we could have
seen all of this coming.
Republican Congressman
Adam Kinzinger
yesterday criticized the GOP
for the ongoing debate
whether to remove
Conference Chair Liz Cheney,
and said the party is
"basically the Titanic."
I don't know, though.
When the "Titanic" went down,
people tried to get off it.
"Women and children first,
and then we party,
right, gentlemen?"
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
signed new voting restrictions
into law last week
at the airport Hilton
in West Palm Beach,
and only allowed Fox News
to broadcast the event.
Also, the airport Hilton
in West Palm Beach
is now Florida's
only polling place.
According to reports, Microsoft
co-founder Bill Gates' wife,
Melinda, may have filed
for divorce
over concerns about her
husband's previous dealings
with sex trafficker
Jeffrey Epstein.
Wow, even Bill Gates has trouble
clearing his history.
According to Politico,
87-year-old Iowa Senator
Chuck Grassley
gets up at 4:00 am every day,
as well as 5:15, 6:00 am,
6:45, and 7:10.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, 87-year-old
Iowa Senator Chuck Grassley
gets up at 4:00 am every day
and often goes for a two-mile
run and does push-ups.
Said Grassley, "I do?"
[ Laughter ]
The manager of a movie theater
in Minnesota
was recently arrested
for allegedly selling cocaine
alongside popcorn,
and was pretty brazen about it.
[ Laughter ]
A small sketch of a bear
by Leonardo da Vinci,
measuring less
than 8 square inches,
is expected to sell
at an auction
for over $16 million,
which is way too high
because da Vinci was originally
trying to draw a dog.
[ Italian accent ]
It's no good.
"No, it's very good."
[ Laughter ]
It's a bear?
"It's a dog!"
[ Laughter ]
Finally, yesterday was singer
Billy Joel's 72nd birthday.
And, this time, he did
almost start the fire.
♪♪
According to reports,
President Biden has yet to have
a medical checkup
since taking office,
but only because the doctor
has been too busy
treating bite wounds.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, President Biden
has yet to have a medical
checkup since taking office.
Alright, let's relax.
It's been four months.
Besides, at his age,
a medical checkup is just
you show up, you pass.
McDonald's will release
new McCafé cups later this year
that include
vaccination information
and federal health slogans
to promote vaccine confidence.
Something like,
"What are you worried about?
You eat here."
[ Laughter ]
Federal investigators
have reportedly asked
a former Capitol Hill intern
who dated Florida
Representative Matt Gaetz
to cooperate with their
investigation into allegations
that Gaetz was involved
in sex trafficking
and, apparently, he still
hasn't learned his lesson.
The U.S. Mint
yesterday announced
it will release a new series
of quarters honoring 20 women,
including poet Maya Angelou
and astronaut Dr. Sally Ride.
What an honor for those women
to be bounced into a SOLO cup
at a college party.
[ Laughter ]
The FDA announced yesterday
that teenagers
from 12 to 15 years old can get
the Pfizer coronavirus vaccine,
but only if they
can figure out how
to sign up for an appointment
on the Inter--
Oh, and they're all signed up.
Okay.
The New York Post published
a list yesterday
of "The 7 craziest,
over-the-top things"
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
has purchased.
Coming in at number 1,
a comb.
[ Laughter ]
NBC announced yesterday
it would not air
next year's Golden Globes,
but only to make room
for their newest program...
[ Laughter ]
Starbucks added a new
strawberry funnel cake
frappuccino to its menu today,
which features strawberry purée
and pieces of powdered sugar
funnel cake,
all for the low, low price
of your foot.
[ Laughter ]
Actress Gwyneth Paltrow
revealed, in a new interview,
that, every night,
during the coronavirus pandemic,
she would drink
two quinoa whiskey cocktails.
Stars!
They're just like
nobody.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
the best way
to regain your smell
after having the coronavirus is
to sniff at least four
different odors twice a day
for several months
or, ladies,
just move in with him.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, a woman in Italy
was released from the hospital
over the weekend,
after she was mistakenly given
six doses of the
Pfizer coronavirus vaccine.
Well, she wasn't released,
so much as she blasted
through the nearest wall.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
House Republicans voted today
to remove GOP
Conference Chair Liz Cheney
from her leadership position,
but they're already claiming
it never happened.
After Congresswoman Liz Cheney
was voted out
of her leadership position,
former President Trump
mocked her on his website,
saying, "I look forward
to soon watching her
as a paid contributor
on CNN or MSDNC,"
said the business genius
who calls in to Fox News
every day for free.
Liz Cheney told reporters today
that she plans to do
everything she can to make sure
former President Trump
"never gets anywhere near
the Oval Office."
Oh, you know what you could do?
Elect him.
Former President Trump's
acting Defense Secretary
Christopher Miller
testified today before Congress
about the Pentagon's response
to the January 6th
Capitol attack
and said he was concerned
that sending troops
would make it look like
a military coup,
as opposed to what
it did look like --
Free Donut Day at the
Krispy Kreme in Middle Earth.
A rare deep-sea creature
called a Pacific Football Fish
washed up on a Southern
California beach last week,
and it already has
a Netflix special.
Kentucky Derby winner
Medina Spirit
will be allowed to compete
this weekend in the Preakness
despite failing a drug test.
The horse will be in stall 6
next to my middle school
bus driver.
According to a new survey,
people in the Northeast
were the most likely to use Zoom
to communicate
a pandemic breakup.
In fact, they even
made it a feature.
A Swedish robotics company
recently unveiled
a battery-operated glove
that can protect factory workers
from chronic injury caused
by repetitive manual tasks.
"Tell me more,"
said teenage boys.
famously a catchphrase
of our nation's teenagers.
"Tell me more."
And finally,
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
announced plans this week
to roll out
pop-up coronavirus
vaccination sites
at trains and subway stations,
because you're not
a real New Yorker
until you've been poked
by a needle on the subway.
♪♪
You guys, I'm not
a superstitious man.
All I'm saying is that Biden
took one picture
with Jimmy Carter,
and now there's a crisis
in the Middle East,
a gasoline shortage,
and low-rise jeans are back.
I don't want to be
disrespectful,
but he might be a leprechaun.
[ As Biden ]
Let me get a picture
with you, Jimmy.
[ Irish accent ]
Oh, you'll get the picture,
alright!
Take it down!
The Colonial Pipeline
restarted operations yesterday,
five days after being shut down
by a cyberattack,
which is good because we were
reaching dangerous levels
of smugness in Tesla owners.
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy yesterday
pushed back against claims
that Republicans are still
focused on the 2020 election
and said, "I don't think anybody
is questioning the legitimacy
of the presidential election."
Added McCarthy, "And I think
Vice President Biden
would agree with that."
That's right,
Kevin McCarthy said that
no one is questioning the
legitimacy of the 2020 election.
Then he said, "Oh,
that's my phone.
Who do I know in Florida?
Oh."
The New York Yankees
announced yesterday
that at least seven members
of the coaching staff
have tested positive
for the coronavirus
despite all receiving
the vaccine.
And that's weird because,
usually,
when Yankees get injections,
they work.
Wally, did you get that one,
Wally? Did you get it?
-No.
-When asked the median price
for a home in Brooklyn,
former City Housing Commissioner
and New York mayoral candidate
Shaun Donovan
vastly underestimated the cost
and said that the average price
of a home is $80,000 to $90,000,
which, in his defense,
is the average price of a home
for your car in Brooklyn.
According to a new study,
the coronavirus can stay
in men's genitals
for a long period of time
after recovery.
Said men, "Challenge accepted."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the United States
is experiencing
a chicken shortage
because roosters are not meeting
breeding expectations.
Said roosters,
"You told people?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Swedish furniture retailer IKEA
announced yesterday
that it will offer --
it will offer
a pulled-pork sandwich
in its restaurants,
if you have the patience
to put it together.
That, you guys, was a monologue.
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]